there are two handsome gorgeous
interesting smart funny brilliantly
talented men about to walk out that's
all you need to
know all you need to
know
I I'm not going to lie I have been
waiting for this day I am so excited our
first guest one is an Oscar nominee for
his role as Elvis Presley I can't even
say that
blessing and the other gentleman has
just been directed by George Clooney in
the boys in the boat and together they
star in the hit miniseries masters of
the air from two up andc coming
producers Steven Spielberg and Tom Hanks
fun fact they're not afraid to shed a
tear watching romcoms what please
welcome Austin Butler and Callum
Turner
so good I'm so nice to
[Applause]
meet you I'm the biggest
F thanks for having us
you rescued these dogs Douglas is a
rescue and he is literally the best dog
and he's 14 I had him when he since he
was 8 weeks old here you go come on come
on wait you guys like romcoms yeah I
love romcoms Yeah well tell me
everything I I mean I spent my life in
that
genre thank
you okay thank
you what wrong do you like and is it
true you're not afraid to shed a tear in
one The Wedding
Singer
yes I got to tell you every time I watch
that movie I'm so glad you're not Julia
gouia thank God I was didn't end up with
Glenn gulia we all have Adam sound saved
you from that he's so I just rewatched
it for the first time in 25 years
because I feel like that's weird to sit
around and watch your own movies it's
too indulgent so no we do it all the
time oh really I was just watching
as you should uh but I saw it and it it
made me cry too mostly for Adam he's so
sweet he is such a good person Robby
Hart is such a kind gentleman that's
right and in this day and age of like
fast-paced romance everything's reduced
down to a text boy did it make me
emotional this the gestures the big
gestures that's what's in I think
chasing you onto the plane and singing
the song you got to have a running you
got to yes you need that at the end of
the movie really ID do too make an
appearance I love that movie well okay
so you were just directed by George
Clooney in boys in the boat and you
were thank you very
much it's so nice to be sitting in front
of an audience too you guys are so cool
we've been bonding all day some of us
are single and trying to figure that out
um are you going to set anyone up
hey okay well we we have a few people
over here um Anna actually asked me what
I was doing tonight um and uh and then I
was like oh my God funny enough I I have
my first date in a long time I'm excited
for your your night tonight I'm not
um I dread these things because they're
yeah they're awkward what are you doing
what what what's the date well first of
all the gentleman offered to pick me up
which I was so bold over by I was like
sure that's a gentlemanly thing to do
and then we were going to go all the way
downtown to this long dinner everyone
says when you go on a date with someone
don't do the dinner do a drink but I
don't know better I like the dinner you
know then you know if it doesn't work
you get to actually talk and yeah it's
you're going to have a great time good
feeling about really yeah I got a good
what if you get weird Vibes right out of
the gate though then what then run yeah
then you go to the bathroom and you call
a friends and and you have them give you
a surprise call do that you want to do
that yes will you please I'll be your
friend really yeah yeah I'm not kidding
I like I'm I get very nervous and I've
never met this person before he's a
complete stranger really that's exciting
it's a blind date if a is it through a
friend meeting on a dating app is a
blind date I'm excited for you well this
is I can't wait to get updates okay
please we might get out of here free
call yeah yeah D you send me a text
later thank you thank you okay um I okay
um so GE Clooney yes now I as an actor I
loved working with him he saved me from
doing things that I don't think were
serving me as an actor like what well he
would say you never keep eye contact
with people in a scene and I'm like well
because it's so intimate do should we
make out while we're at it like eye
contact is insane see I'm feeling the
pressure to not take my eyes up for you
right now it's a very big deal in life
contct I almost feel like it's a little
invasive and so I sort of shy away from
it but George helped me realize I should
not do that okay um is it true that you
only had like a week in between Elvis
and coming to Masters of the air what
was that emotional whip lash like it was
wild so I I had been working on Elvis
for 3 years I can't and then I I can't
now this is my first
crush he's My First Crush I love him and
you were
and I'm so happy that you got so
recognized for that that you were so
honored and it was so you know everybody
came to the Forefront to admire your
hard work and effort and saw what you
put into it w thank you drew that was so
deserved means a lot it's true oh my God
he's My First Crush who is your first
crush
[Music]
[Applause]
who was your first crash um I think like
tapanga on what was that show was that
Bor was that was that right Save By the
Bell boy me world which one is it boy me
world TOA I remember having a crush on
her okay Callum who was your first crush
uh mine was Jessica Rabbit Jessica RAB
that's a good one that woman did so much
for so many for so many yeah um okay so
you have one week to go from Elvis you
became him I mean it just I how do you
get out of that I wrapped and the next
morning I I thought my appendix had
burst and I ended up spending a week in
in bedridden after I finished Elvis and
then I flew straight to London and when
I when I got there it was still Co so I
had 10 days to
so then I just I read the novel you know
for masters of the air and I watched
Banda Brothers again in the Pacific and
started to just immerse myself in that
world and thankfully we had we had this
boot camp as soon as I got out of
quarantine that helps and so we had two
weeks of of you know I'd been in white
jumpsuits up until that point and now
here I was just one of the guys in
fatigues and so it really bonded us it
bonded the entire there was 120 of us in
this boot camp I feel like you're Julia
watching Robbie and The Wedding Singer
you're watching him perform and sing and
I was just channeling you yes exactly
doing it like fresh I I I love this
series and I think it's so honoring um
tellum is it true that you have
something for
me yeah we yeah we do actually yeah oh
yeah can that we bought you a jacket
really let's
here one the authentic jackets that that
we wor the A2 jacket you ready oh yes I
am get in there Dre thank
you you're a member of the crew now I
feel so honored because this show is so
incredibly important um will you guys
play one of my favorite games the final
five absolutely great okay it's the
final
five you doing okay Austin Callum what
is a secret skill of yours I I can make
a rose out of a paper napkin wonderful
do you bust it out sometimes for special
occasions they're bringing a paper
napkin no they
aren't Callum secret scale yeah uh I can
fall asleep very
quickly um okay what is part of your
nighttime routine that you will never
give up I love taking a shower before
bed oh it really it's simple but I just
love getting the bed clean you know that
feeling no I don't because my hair stays
wet for 10 years and I feel like a soggy
hot dog and I hate it I will never
shower before bed really the body yes
the hair no yeah you know what do you do
before bed you know what I do I do wle
oh I love W I always go to bed at like
12:00 and then it's the new one so I I
get in there and show off to my friends
shower and whle there you go all right
in this Modern Age of love what is
something romantic that needs to stay
alive I think writing love
letters you know little notes how and
what's something that's I say yeah I was
going to say love letters as well you I
think so yeah I think writing to each
other is a beautiful thing okay I hate
goats cheese I hate it with a passion
what's a Kryptonite for you well the one
we disagree on is is Mite oh yeah you
don't like you guys have that hair it's
disgusting it's horrible it's horrible G
it's dis see I I SP a lot of time in
Australia and they would they would put
it on crumpets and stuff and I got to a
point where I I actually looked forward
to it in the morning they wo you down
yeah I was going to say they broke you
okay so you guys became besties tell us
something that we don't know about the
other person Callum I'd love to start
with you well Austin he loves uh pottery
and he's a damn good Potter
too Patrick S and ghost like ghost yeah
exactly all right what's one thing about
Callum we don't know uh one something
that I truly respect about you is that
you he's really good at keeping in touch
with people and like nurturing
friendships the other thing is he has a
Spanish tutor and and he's uh he's very
good at speaking Spanish it's true I
speak Spanish yeah TI graas yeah you
guys thank you so
much thank you for having the generosity
of your time so douy okay masters of the
air is streaming now on Apple TV plus it
is a wonderful important meaningful
beautiful magnanimous show and I thank
you both uh as well as Tom Hanks and
Steven Spielberg for putting another
piece of History out into the world um
and we'll be right
back